meet juno the first debit card that lets
you spend cash and crypto while earning
five percent cashback that's right over
50 000 people use their juno card to get
five percent cash back at places like
amazon doordash uber and more it's free
to use anywhere around the world where
mastercard is accepted and unlike credit
cards there are no annual fees or hidden
charges it's completely free to sign up
and if you set up a direct deposit of
250 or more you could upgrade to their
metal program which comes with higher
cash limits and a metal debit card and
even when you're not spending your money
juno makes sure that your money is
always growing with their 1.2 apy on all
cash balances that's 20 better than the
average savings account that's pretty
good that's really good you can also get
free atm access at over 80 000 locations
at places like walgreens cvs 711 and
more juno has no minimum balance
requirements no monthly fees and no
overdraft fees too so sign up for the
free card today to start earning five
percent cash back at some of your
favorite brands like doordash and amazon
plus you could get 10 on your first
deposit and a hundred dollars on your
first direct deposit just by using the
link down below in the description again
check out that link down below in the
description with juno to manage all of
your cash and your crypto in one amazing
account and now with that said let's get
back to the podcast welcome back to the
iced coffee hour my name is lucky lopez
with automotive life and so far the iced
coffee hour podcast has made 239
thousand dollars 633 cents that's the
closest guest we've ever had yeah ever
232
300
ooh what do i win
a high five man
this is this is a trip because we've
been friends with you for i don't even
know how long maybe a year right yeah
technically it was a year when we went
to uh barrett-jackson actually they just
reached out to me they're like are you
guys coming are you guys coming because
hoovy was there again and it's already
been a year that's crazy just flew by
it's insane we've hung out a ton in this
past year and something with your sector
of your business has been going crazy
that's why we brought you on we think
you can explain something going on with
the car bubble the auto market bubble
car values have gone up more by the way
than real estate the s p 500
collectibles uh people don't realize
that cars over these last two years are
up
i think it's 33 yeah no i think it's
even higher i think so use cars 33 new
cars they have uh above msrp purchase
prices like the new corvette of 50 60
000
i tried to buy one of the new ford
broncos and they want 35 000 over msrp
and a brand new ford broncos like 37 000
was what i was looking at so it's almost
the same price as the car which just
blows my mind people don't realize that
back when covid first hit
you would you would have been best off
just buying a whole bunch of used cars
over stocks or real estate yeah
outperformed crypto stocks everything
else i remember when the epidemic first
hit i had a few uh dealerships reached
out to me and they were doing fire sales
they were so afraid that the banks are
going to shut down everything's going to
end so my friends were giving away
trucks and all this stuff and then all
of a sudden they ran out of trucks the
supply ended and then they started
buying everything else and the numbers
just shot up through the roof blew me
away so what's your experience going
into this like your credibility in terms
of like what you see can you tell us
like how you're involved in the auto
industry okay so um i've been in the
automotive business for over 20 years
i've had multiple dealerships here in
vegas auto repair shops owned a few
rental car companies and what i
currently do now on my channel is
basically teach people how to set up
their automotive business and so still
today to keep my feet wet to make sure i
don't look like a fake guru i always try
to go out and still buy cars still
wholesale still broke or still buy paper
stuff like that and what we've been
seeing is just astronomical it's the
first time ever in history that a
depreciating asset like a car is
actually going up in value for the last
two and a half years which just blows my
mind and the whole thing about i guess
the market right now is people feeling
that there's this big shortage there's
this big belief that there's not enough
cars coming out of the factory and it's
the completely the opposite every chip
manufacturer we talked to is currently
building if you call chevy right now and
say hey you know what i need a new
computer for my 2022 chevy corvette
call them
they'll get it in like seven days so
when we showed people this online and we
showed a few of the news conferences i
did they were blown away they thought
that everything was backorder the only
place i know that has backordered parts
is tesla because
tesla's not the greatest which we can
get into you also hate tesla you say
it's like your least favorite car make
ever right yeah i mean it's i mean i
like the car they're the first to market
with a lot of the great stuff that came
out the self-driving going 100 electric
so i do commend them on that but they
tried so hard to be a tech company in an
automotive industry and it's just it's
such a pain in the butt because like if
you know like your lexus has issues we
can literally walk in i can hey i got
this car here's the vin number i could
pick up the parts if they don't have it
they'll tell me when it comes in try
doing that a tesla i have friends that
have literally been waiting weeks if not
months and tesla will not tell them when
their parts are coming in if anybody's
ever crashed to tesla before or dealt
with this they totally know what i'm i
mean it's impossible to get parts and
then if you try to do service you
usually want to call a service writer
explain our problems our issues you guys
using the apps i don't know how you do
it it's like yeah pick up my car where's
your car i don't know it's somewhere and
it's dead and ran out of juice and it's
like they got to pick it up from
wherever you actually got to direct them
to it and you got to stand there with
your phone so it's just a few things
that are not very convenient and they're
trying to buck that system of using
automotive professionals in their system
which i kind of understand they want to
make it different but if you want
somebody working on your car i'm sure
you'd probably feel better if somebody
worked under multiple cars for multiple
years when i was talking to some of
these tesla techs and i was like oh what
did you do before were you like at
ferrari mercedes bmw jaguar ford oh no i
was uh i was an engineer for um you know
like cisco systems and i'm like
so you did like software setups and and
everything else they're like yeah and i
was like then what are you working on
tesla's he's like oh it's very simple we
just
they don't fix anything you just replace
and so it kind of blew my mind so i'm
sure i'm going to get roasted in the
comment section for all the tesla fans
because i know you guys have a bunch of
them but it's completely different from
most dealerships they don't like to
share information like when i was fixing
spencer's car i can look up online and
say if you crashed your lotus i can tell
you how many hours it's going to take to
take off your bumper where i can get the
parts how far back ordered i am and give
you an accurate quote on how to fix your
car
tesla does not share any of this
information so when i'm calling like hey
like especially if the car is wrecked i
don't know what was there before and i'm
like hey i need to get some bolts and
parts what was here before can i get a
diagram is that because tesla likes to
repair their own cars though 100 they
really really want to do their own thing
and repair their own cars but they're
running into the big problem of you know
there's not a tesla facility you know in
a lot of states and a lot of cities so
then they're subbing them out to other
people so i have a friend that's in
california that does tesla repair and
he's a certified shop through them and
it's still a pain in the butt to get
parts and to work with them so during
covid which cars did you see
have the biggest increase in value
what do people want the most i was
actually shocked i figured it was going
to be like luxury suvs or luxury cars it
was trucks hands down
anything that makes money i've never
seen dodge ford chevy and even some of
the nissan trucks and sprinter vans just
absolutely explode in price
you know usually trucks we use them for
work we beat them up and and they take a
beating in the depreciates a little bit
but trucks usually hold their value i
mean these guys were asking for sixty
thousand dollars over on a gmc denali
which i was just shocked i'm like this
is just a truck i know it's a nice truck
but why sixty thousand dollars over and
they're like well you can't get them
even though they got 13 of them sitting
right there on the lot um i think that
those were really big hit and then also
anything that was kind of rare like
you're you're tesla now um some of these
like ford uh shelby mustangs they didn't
make a lot of them so they just shot up
anything with limited amount of of
inventory blew up even my audi like i've
owned it for a year
put 17 000 miles on it and it's worth
more today than when i bought it a year
ago here's a question for you why
wouldn't the auto manufacturers see this
that people are paying these prices
why don't they just say all right well
that's the new price now
we'll just make fewer of them and sell
it at that price that's so i i talk
about that on my channel and it's kind
of like a conspiracy thing when people
ask me what there's a shortage there's a
shortage and i'm like
if you're producing a hundred thousand
cars
and grossing thirty thousand dollars
over msrp why would you make three
hundred thousand cars and break even and
have to give them away because i
remember two years ago we were getting
stuff back of msrp they were literally
giving us vehicles like when i bought my
mercedes i literally got it for less
than wholesale
and then when this happened like you can
go to ford chevy whatever else you'll
see that the lines are moving smoothly
the only actual uh
i guess supply shortage that i've seen
was uh wiring harnesses for european
vehicles because the main manufacturers
in ukraine
but i believe that's why they're doing
that and the sad thing is it's not even
the manufacturers the manufacturers give
the suggested retail price it's the
dealers
they get to set whatever market price
they want to so a lot of people keep
blaming like ford honda chevy toyota and
it's actually the dealers the
franchisees that are adjusting the
prices how do dealers work exactly
because i know it's kind of a
complicated more than comp more than
what meets the i complicated situation
right yeah right now there's a the way
dealerships work is is very old school
but it is
sought out and it works and it functions
but i'll kind of go into this right now
everybody's trying to do what tesla's
doing tesla's doing direct to consumer i
thought ford is copying that is the
first one that made a separate uh llc
that's going to try to do their ev
vehicles but still service them at their
four dealers so this way they don't get
sued by their franchisees which is going
to happen
but the way a dealership works is you
know you make a contract with somebody
like ford and you say look we're going
to we want to sell your cars when you
sign that contract you have to uphold a
certain standard of not only your
building but also a service department
you got to buy so much in parts every
month and then you also got to get so
many cars allocuted so if you love
everybody wants trucks they're all
fighting for trucks but you still have
to buy the ford escapes the the ford
focuses the evs whatever that's not
popular you still have to buy because
that's part of your contract of being a
ford dealer but with that if you have
good customer service you have really
high reports and people are happy with
you you get specialty vehicles like
ford's svt so the ford gt you weren't
allowed to sell those unless you were a
dealer with a really high csi report
which all your customers raved about you
and they thought you're really good
but when it comes to dealers
i do admit that the way they function is
very outdated especially when it comes
to finance i can literally tell you a
million horror stories of how financing
works because when we tell like people
even like when i had my dealership here
and i would tell them how it works they
never believed me and now that like i
talk about it on the channel people
still laugh but finance is probably one
thing let's talk about finances because
when i saw your video originally i did a
lot of research into everything that you
said and what i found the most
surprising was that it's common to get a
loan up to a hundred and thirty percent
of the car's value so if you have a car
jack that you want to buy for ten
thousand dollars you could find a bank
who will finance that car for thirteen
thousand dollars thirty percent more and
the reason is because they they add in
the sales tax the registration the
titling fees and all the other
miscellaneous stuff up to a hundred and
thirty percent and i'm thinking how are
they doing that with a car that loses
twenty percent as soon as it drives off
the lot and all of a sudden a person
knows fifty percent more than what the
car is worth within like a week yeah how
could you explain like the process of
this
yeah so that's that's actually the
average now 130 percent we have some
banks that go up to 170 percent of ltv
which is just mind-blowing what's
yeah the way they did it is they were
saying they were adjusting for inflation
because as you guys know with
the pandemic and the vehicle shortage
all the cars started rising up in price
so what the banks did the dealerships
did the combat is like well if i'm
paying let's say the car's worth 25
thousand dollars if i'm going to the
auction paying 25 grand i still got to
make a profit so then i would show this
slip to the bank and say i need to get
more money i need to make five six
thousand dollars on this deal can you
finance it up to 150 percent of ltv and
at that time the government was pretty
much obviously giving people stimulus
money and they were backing all these
loans so they're like yeah just go ahead
and i've never seen banks change their
lending so quickly and so freely where
before like even when i bought my r8
didn't even ask me for a proof of income
they didn't ask for proof of residence
they just kind of bent the rules and
traditionally we only do that if the
customer has good credit and a good
history
and what happened during the pandemic is
they just literally let the floodgates
go so if you had let's say you were a
waiter and you made 2500 a month you
know and you just let's say become a
plumber and now you're making 35 40 an
hour normally what we would do is we
would say okay that's an actual
profession we would give you more loan
to compensate for your new income
if it's something like seasonal work or
something that's temporary like stimulus
money we don't ever give you more money
because we know that that's only
temporary it's going to go back down to
normal well during this pandemic they
were like oh well this guy's making four
grand his his spouse is making four
grand and they're not paying rent and
they're putting 20 30 percent down let's
just give them 150 160 percent and
they're just giving away all this money
these over inflated numbers and the
banks were just taking it because they
figured okay if worst case scenario
happens we're just going to bundle this
paper you know get a triple a rated sell
it out to somebody and either one of the
banks is there no oversight is there no
one who has a standard on these loans
and they say this person is getting
money from unemployment they cannot
afford this once that runs out
there's not like an authority there
there is every bank kind of governs
themselves there's fbic has regulations
for certain types of lending like
predatory lending it came really big
back in the day i could sell you a
hundred thousand dollar car for three
hundred thousand dollars and there's
nothing you could do as long as you sign
a contract you're on the hook now it's
got to be somewhat in a certain range
where we can't oversell to you but i
believe after this they're going to make
a lot more regulations
now that the default rates are going up
and banks are seeing this they're
starting to pull back their books but
yeah the banks regulate themselves and a
lot of these banks if they get their
money from like wells fargo bank of
america they have to abide by their
guide roles but there's so many of these
hedge funds and bigger money that's
private money that's investing into
these banks they can write whatever they
want i'm sure you've all noticed the
recent dip in crypto and it's kind of
nerve-wracking but it also presents an
interesting opportunity to buy that's a
really good point jack and when you're
buying cryptocurrency it's extremely
important to use a brokerage that's not
only trustworthy but also saves you on
fees of which our sponsor ftx has fees
that are up to 85 percent lower than the
top competitors they also allow you to
set up automatic recurring buys so that
you could dollar cost average to the
markets on a regular basis and buying is
incredibly easy you type in exactly what
you want to buy how much of it you want
to buy how often you want to buy it and
then they give you free crypt on every
single trade you make over ten dollars
and if you guys don't trust us trust the
millions of other users that ftx has
because they are one of the most trusted
and reputable platforms out there right
now there are no fees whatsoever when
you trade crypto and nfts they're soon
launching ftx stocks so they're gonna be
an all-in-one inclusive trading platform
trade crypto nfts and stocks all for
free it's gonna be amazing nftx also
recently spent 250 million dollars
expanding its equity trading
infrastructure to ensure that even their
stock trades don't have fees check out
ftx with that link down below in the
description it also really helps support
the podcast which means a lot to us and
keeps us going again use the link down
below in the description to get started
today and now with that said let's get
back to the podcast this kind of sounds
like the 08 housing crisis
it does for cars yes 100 like we were
making that joke it's like you know they
at least back then you know people were
losing their repos i think it was like
that it was about fourteen percent
thirteen five um was the repo rate back
then but people you know were so upset
on their houses that's why they let them
go now we have people that have houses
but they actually have equity but you
look at the cars once that that market
starts to dip like right now
retailers are talking about slowing down
less bank loans are being given interest
rates are going up people don't have the
money that they used to so now all these
dealers are stuck with this overpriced
inventory and we're watching the numbers
go down and i think that's one of the
hottest topics that i talk about is like
you could see it come down and i hear
people well the dealer won't go down on
his price i'm like give it time it's
it's happening we've seen all the repos
like the video you guys saw it's all
piling up but i think it's going to come
to full ahead probably within the next
three to six months when we talked about
it about six months ago people thought
it was weird and you know tin foil hat
and whole
shebang
now when i'm starting like with news
companies asking for interviews and
people are sharing my stuff like on
reddit forums and twitter now it's like
it's kind of nice to see that the cracks
the foundation are showing people are
actually scared and people like yourself
and your guys's channel that are more
well-known are talking about it because
it's going to be a really really big
deal
what's your prediction on what will
happen
my thing is i honestly believe that
we're going to have probably not a big
collapse like like the house market it's
going to be like a 20 30 percent dip but
it's not the price of the car that's
going to scare everybody it's the
ability to finance once these banks like
you know what mortgage and stuff like
that a lot of them were
government-backed they were able to pawn
them off whatever else a lot of these
automotive loans are not like that
they're not backed by the government
they're sold to these hedge funds um
people got them in their mutual funds
you know so they're just sitting there
and if they default the banks when they
show that much of negative equity in
their portfolio they're going to stop
lending they're going to make it
extremely strict just like they did
after the housing market where
i'm going to go off your income and you
could only afford what i can say you can
afford and that's what basically people
are pushing themselves and doing is to
being governed by people because the
access of you know i know people i won't
mention names here in vegas that live in
a thousand dollar a month apartment but
drive a 200 000 car
why we got to name names we got to know
yeah who is it it's that guy but uh but
that's like some of the stuff that we're
seeing and so that shouldn't happen but
i believe that that's probably gonna be
the next step is if this collapses as
bad as what they say it is i think the
government's gonna step in just like the
last time we're predatory lending and
they're going to change a lot of it but
i think it should be like that it to me
that seems reasonable that there should
be a standard that says if you don't
make a certain amount of money you
shouldn't qualify for this payment yeah
i mean there's there's pros and cons to
each of that it's just like at the end
of the day if if you make let's say 20
bucks an hour but you have 200 000 in
the bank and you want to buy a lambo for
300k i mean to me you have the down
payment you should be financially sound
enough but the bank's gonna look and
she'd be like this guy only makes 20
bucks an hour why are we why are we
gonna take his 200k and he's not gonna
be able to afford the payment we know
you can you could be successful you
could be rich it could be on social
security and they still won't take it
they're even bucking like um
the original loans they used to ask for
like your bank statements your w-2s some
sort of paper trail you know to justify
that they stopped asking that because
when
the bill of rights came out with this
new federal
uh credit protection where it's
predatory lending if they know that you
make too much or you don't make enough
and they don't give you the loan all
these banks are worrying about getting
sued because they'd rather give you a 30
000 car and if you fail
that's on you if you succeed great but
if they show that they did some sort of
malfeasance or they were judging you by
your income or your character or your
race or whatever else they get like a 30
000 fine from the fdic and so that's
some of the stuff that they're really
really scared about so it's weird it's
like they want you to verify everything
but then they want to push the documents
out and sell the car and not have to
worry about who they're selling it to so
what do you think that's going to do to
car values
let's start with new cars oh geez so
you know we talked about how the msrp
people are asking like 20 30 000 over it
um just last week we were able to get a
lamborghini huracan or technica here in
vegas nothing over msrp i can get a new
corvette nothing over msrp um a lot of
the allocations they were talking about
how oh it's it's going to be 18 months
it's going to be 24 months before you
get your car now we're down to like
eight 12 months so the i believe that
the market's going to start cooling down
already like if you drive by sahara you
can see the lots are full of cars you
know there are some spots here um in the
united states that have low inventory
especially when it comes to the
northeast they just i don't know why
they just don't have a lot of cars here
or the west coast we have these massive
lots so they just stack three 400 cars
and just leave them you know and if you
watch my video a lot of these banks and
even some of these dealerships have
holding yards so even though they do
have inventory sometimes we don't show
you everything like if you look at my
lot you'd never guess how many cars i
got i got a 150 cars but that's like i
said it's just from back there i put a
few up online a few at the auction and i
think that's what's going on so do you
think the worst case scenario for new
cars then is just selling at msrp that
doesn't seem that no bad that's from
that perspective yeah the prices like i
said it's it doesn't seem that bad until
the people try to go buy them when their
rent is doubled the gas is doubled their
insurance is doubled and they're trying
to maybe afford a 600 car payment that's
what they qualify for maybe this new car
that's at msrp is 750 now they're not
going to qualify for it that's my big
worry is that people are not going to
qualify for these types of vehicles
anymore because of they're going to get
stricter they're going to ask for more
down payment they're going to ask for
better stability because a lot of my
banks like as a dealer every few months
we get
a notification from our lenders hey we
want to do 2015 and above we want to
state cars 105 000 miles and below we
don't do
maybe mercedes or we don't do anything
rare like saabs they'll send you out
these um structures to let you know what
to lend on how to set it up and i've
noticed that we used to get these maybe
once a quarter we're getting these
things every two to three weeks now of
we're not doing this anymore we're not
doing 84 months we're not doing 2.9
we're going back up to 3.5 uh minimum
job time instead of one month it's six
months
so little by little it's like i said
it's starting to show and bubble to the
surface but the problem is the public
won't see this for another three to six
months it's the dealers and the people
inside the industry that are seeing it
now but they will never see it because
they're the ones that are holding all
the inventory and they don't get stuck
with a bunch of overpriced stuff what
about used cars
used cars
here's the problem if you're buying
something under twelve thousand dollars
i think those cars are gonna go up
because once just like in oh eight um
that's why i started selling like more
cheap affordable cars is because people
can't afford those 30 40 50 60 000 cars
after their credit shot after they don't
make as much money or their debt to
income is not what it's supposed to be
so anything under 12 grand i believe is
gonna hold its value if not go up like
your miata you're gonna laugh and two
years from now i bet you'll be worth
double what we bought it for
you know it's it's just i think it's
almost already there you know but uh
it's that's what we're seeing is people
that normally didn't have money during
that stimulus time they got those back
checks they were getting five ten
fifteen thousand dollars at one time
they were buying all cheap affordable
cash cars so there are some people that
were smart after the 08 recession that
like i'm not going to get myself in debt
i'm going to buy something cash own it
and have no bills so when people ask me
what's the hardest cars to get it's
cheap cars i mean alex knows i've been
trying to find him a truck forever you
know when we were looking for your miata
it's anything that's affordable is super
super expensive and it's almost like
doubled you know where before i could
get you that miata for like two grand
now it's like four actually no no it's
like six to eight thousand dollars for a
decent one you know without being beat
up no what about cars like the ford gt
for like collector cars like an sls amg
a z8
all of these cars have gone up like 50
to sometimes they've doubled some of
some have tripled the dodge vipers now
oh my gosh nobody wanted those cars for
years and now i'm looking at the values
and bring a trailer they're
selling it ridiculous amounts right now
yeah
with specialty cars like yours
i hate to say it it's only worth what
somebody's willing to pay for it yeah
the more where they are obviously
they're going to hold their value but
what we've been seeing is a lot of
people liquidating a lot of their uh
their collections you know like you like
your ford gt i would just keep it
because even if it drops 20 30 percent i
would still get it because you'll never
know when you'll be able to get another
one
but we've seen a lot of the exotic cars
like barrett jackson was just here
hundreds of cars go up bring a trailer
cars and bids all these places um one
interesting statistic that i saw
that was saying that fifty percent of
the buyers on bring a trailer and cars
and bids are dealers now i can't confirm
this i've yeah so i
watch those bids religiously i have so
much fun sometimes i'll send jack the
cool ones we'll all watch it together
with uh alex too and uh i click on the
profiles of the people that are bidding
on the cars and i'm like what what are
they buying
some of them you know they're
individuals when they bought very
specific cars and maybe they're building
a collection of like only buying red
cars and like they're all red but then
some i've seen that they're buying like
30 cars a month and they're all in like
different price points so and sometimes
i feel like are those are they bidding
on behalf of someone else who just hires
them to go and buy these cars you're
saying you're dealers yeah most of them
were dealers like i was shocked like
when i put my smart car up there i
figured it's a fun toy somebody just
wants to buy it for fun
i'd say about 80 of those when i was
messaging them back and forth and some
hit me up on instagram they're all
dealers what are they gonna do with that
flip it oh yeah one guy said that he had
he was gonna finance some guy for thirty
five thousand dollars and i was like
you're gonna sell the smart car for 35
grand and he's like yeah he goes i got a
guy he's got 10 grand cash he just can't
afford it and the bid right now is like
11 grand i was like
you know if that's what you want to do
but there were so many dealers like they
had inside deals with banks just kind of
like what i have where we could finance
almost whatever we want now how does
that work let's say
they're bidding on behalf of a person
like that what's to say they don't win
the car then the person backs out that's
the problem that's why i don't do auto
brokering when people ask me like why
don't you go to the auction and show me
how to buy cars or take me with you i
want to buy a car it's not worth it
because that's what they do
i don't like the color i don't like the
smell you know i thought it'd be nicer
in person so yeah that's the run the
risky run but a lot of these dealers
they just had a blank check you know
with the stimulus money and ppp loans
like i'll tell you what that's what i
think that drove up the the highline
prices because i remember same thing we
bought a viper for like 38 000 bucks i
think that thing sold just recently for
like 70 80 000
i've been trying to buy a delorean for
like six months i can't even touch them
they just they i've never seen them for
like 10 15 20 000
now not even running 30 grand it's
interesting because we uh we got the
lotus wrapped
check out the graham stefan after hours
channel we're going to post there uh
sometime soon but anyway we'll throw up
a picture here from purpleflare apps and
i was talking to the owner
and i said how's the business going and
he said that people are
preparing right now for a recession
and they're buying fewer cars they're
spending less money customizing their
cars and like he in my opinion is one of
the perfect people to talk to on this
because he sees it firsthand when you're
spending money on a car rap chances are
you're doing well
enough to spend you know whatever on a
wrap but when people are scaling back on
that and they're preparing for this um
and at the same time that you're seeing
people selling off a lot of those cars
like a lot of the ford gts are being
sold and bring a trailer and it makes me
kind of think hmm they're all selling
these cars why why are they selling them
um so i could definitely see us
potentially heading in that direction
where people are beginning to sell off
their cars just
to prepare for maybe what might happen
yeah i i think that that fear is already
out there and especially a lot of people
learned after 08 where i remember the
economy is great the government said the
same thing the economy is great we're
going to keep booming there's no
problems and all of a sudden it just
it fell out and so now like same thing
with me i'm trying not to listen to
different people like trying to
influence my decision like whether to
sell cars buy cars but my advice would
be if if you can afford it like your
ford gt you love it it's your dream car
it's actually my dream car too i would
keep it i wouldn't get rid of it have
you found the the car market to be a
leading indicator of bigger economic
problems or like a following i i usually
do because we we talk about the subprime
auto market like that's one of the
things that when we start to see repos
piling up we start to see defaults
that's usually the first indicator of us
like the economy's slowing down the jobs
are not as great so we like i said we're
kind of talking about this on my channel
about six months ago and everybody's
like man we're struggling to hire people
and i'm sure you guys have seen like you
know we're dying for people we're trying
to mgm grand was offering bonuses here a
lot of my friends owned restaurants were
offering bonuses
was it last month month before
stopped like instantly everybody put
hiring holds they stopped doing it a lot
of these tech companies are laying off
hundreds of people if not thousands
carvana laid off is it 2500 people which
we have to talk about them too that's
like the worst but that's one of the
things that we see is we see that about
six months to a year before like the
real estate market when people started
defaulting on their cars and letting
them go we were wondering why so many
people were doing it we figured it's
because they were buying too many houses
because everybody we knew even the
walmart greeter owned three homes in
vegas you know from those ninja loans
but we started seeing all these people
letting their cars go and we didn't
think anything of it we're just like
we're just gonna buy these and turn on
and sell them and then it just slapped
us in the face
you know thank god i was able to
liquidate a lot of them but a lot of my
friends they didn't come back from that
they lost a lot of money so i do see
that that's kind of the main indicator
of what's going on because people i
think now instead of the other way
around they would always get rid of
they'd stop paying their house get their
car and then just drive around their car
now i think it's the other way around
they're just going to get rid of their
cars keep their house because they got
equity because why pay
40 000 for a dodge charger when you
could see one in six months from now
selling for 25 000 at a dealership for
half the price and half the car payment
i feel that's what's going to happen
people are going to start letting stuff
go and buying it back for for cheaper
just like it was in the weight with
houses now you're mentioning carvana
could you explain what's going on with
them
so carvana is another one of those
companies that wants to be a tech
company first and then a car dealership
second which the theory sounds great it
was like the darling of the stock market
a while back and so
um i personally dealt with them on
several occasions when about maybe
about four years ago we used to fix
their cars my dealership was right
across the street from drive time which
is also owned by the same family it's a
father and son duo and so they would buy
the cars carvana would pay to fix them
and then after they fixed them they
would sell them to drive time
and then they would pay for like little
minor repairs and send them back and
like why are they guys why are these
guys taking such big losses you know and
they're not making any money on these
cars why are they selling to to drive
them doesn't make any sense so we just
thought new company they made mistakes
with buying they didn't have any
qualified employees they were buying
stuff virtual online
so they're one of the first ones to do
that so we're like okay it's just
learning learning pains well fast
forward three years later nothing has
changed you know if you're one of the
biggest automotive companies that's
buying and selling cars to people you
know
you want to be to have the smartest
people in the room you want to hire the
best qualified people when you go to
most caravana stores there's no store
it's just a person driving around a
truck the buyers for the cars it's
usually maybe a guy that's never really
bought a whole lot of cars they just go
around and just pick up cars that you
enter online they look at the calculator
which we'll show you here just come up
with some formulated plan on how much
it's worth and you just pay you for it i
have videos where we sold cars to
carvana that were just absolute junk and
they were paying us you know three four
or five thousand dollars over market
value and the kid wouldn't even start it
like we gave them the keys and you know
we put like squeaky toys in the seat and
like funny stuff on the steering wheel
just so it it'd be funny when he walked
in he just looked at it okay that's the
car i'm like yeah i was like here's the
title okay here's your check and just
walk back in didn't start it didn't look
at it and it blew my mind and then that
was the beginning of the end because
when we made that video
they started being sued by multiple
people people were selling flood cars
damaged cars salvage cars people were
duplicating titles and duplicating vins
which that's why they were getting sued
like in texas and chicago because they
were i'm selling people stolen cars
so imagine buying a car from a reputable
massive dealership you know and then
finding out that it's stolen and then
the feds come banging on your door
because the gps says it's over here or
they they tried to go get it fixed at a
dealership and they ran the van and they
found out it was it was stolen so they
had multiple lawsuits and then on top of
that as a dealer you know you're
supposed to be in charge of your
paperwork so if you buy a car from me
i'm on a time limit i got to get you
your title or the bank the title within
30 days
and they don't hire anybody that does
title clerk and they always send it out
to some third-party company so they got
their license almost pulled in texas
illinois and florida because of that
they're actually they got they were able
to grace buy it they had to buy back i
think it was like 200 cars from people
but now they're being sued again because
people have been waiting six seven
months they still haven't gotten their
plates
they still haven't gotten their titles
and the the scary thing is is
they lose about 25 to 3 500 per car on
every transaction so their joke was
we're going to buy odessa which is a
major auto auction if we buy this
auction we're going to be able to lower
our costs by a thousand dollars by
shipping and by repairing your cars but
if you're losing two thousand dollars a
car it doesn't matter if you save a
thousand you're still upside down a
grand and so they did that just for
another round of funding
just to basically kick the can down the
road so i don't even know how they're
doing this but we were talking about
this when their stock was i think at
like 310 and we're just like oh man if i
i'm not much of a trader but like if i
could short them i would short the hell
out of them and next thing you know i
think it's now what 27 26 dollars you
know is what their their shares are
trading at and the worst thing is is
they keep getting bailed out by these
companies and it blows my mind how
people are just so blindly giving these
people money like oh this this is legit
we're just we're taking a market share
that's the tech way market share market
share market share we don't have to show
you anything that makes money just
marketing so bad zillow was doing the
exact same thing when they were buying
properties it was the zillow instant
offers where basically you could go on
you type in your address you give them
information and they'll spit you out an
offer and they'll buy your house cash um
and all they'll do is they'll send one
rep to go and just you know take a
visual once over make sure everything's
fine make sure the roof
but yeah but uh people started reporting
that zillow was paying five percent over
uh what people were getting in terms of
their offers an already inflated value
zilla will come in and beat that by five
percent just to buy the property and
people started reporting on reddit first
uh before they discontinued people
showed that they would sell their house
to zillow and stun offers they would
wait a month they'd see zillow list the
house on zillow
no offers and then they would reduce the
price below what they paid for it yeah
and so people were joking be like well
i'm gonna sell my house to zillows and
offers so i could buy it back cheaper
but but basically the whole business
model was broken because the people that
they hired didn't care i mean they were
just hiring so many people who just
had a quotas to phil i'm sure it's just
like okay we gotta buy x amount of
houses to buy market share and that's
how they uh spun it that yeah it's a
temporary loss but we're going to take
over the market with instant offers and
people are going to use us yeah uh and
then they discontinue that yeah and so
that that was their their leverage like
well if we buy an auction house we could
control the flow of vehicles so if we
over pay for a car too much we'll just
take it to the auction and get our money
back and they are literally losing their
ass on every single car and the worst
thing is is i think that their last
round of funding got turned down i think
they were trying to go after like
another 110 million i think they only
got approved for i think it was like 80
million and so now they're like
basically running on
just a very bare-bones skeleton crew
trying to get as much money but they're
still losing they're saying it's even
more now it's 2700
average per car so if they keep losing
this money i don't see how they're going
to last within the next six months to a
year but that's what most of the the
news outlets went into that video that's
what they all wanted to interview about
was they're they're all betting the same
thing they called it a ponzi scheme so i
didn't say it but they did but that's
what they believe that it is because all
their loans i thought it was a lead gen
for their loan company because they own
bridge crest and another company that
does all their loans and so you know
think about it if you're getting a
billion dollars in loans at average
let's say five to eight percent i mean
the interest you're going to make on
that is just astronomical so even if
they file bankruptcy on carvana they can
hang out for the next three to five
years and make all that money not
including that the father and the son
were selling off stock at the 300 uh
dollar peak as it wrote its way down
they stopped selling because they pretty
much ran out of stock so it's very
interesting if you get time look up that
it blows my mind i'm i'm not much on
that end but when i saw what they were
doing i'm like nobody's noticing this
and now everybody's just like oh my god
it's a sham it's a sham and i'm like i
should have said it about a year ago wow
how do people make money from this
well i can't give out financial advice
but i can say that if you're gonna
short or bet against anybody i would
definitely do any type of major
institution like this ally ally has
their own they're publicly traded right
like they're i remember their ceo went
on tv saying that they're doing great
and they're they have the highest uh
prime loan default rate out of all the
banks from what i saw on a bank sheet
yeah it's them wells fargo bank of
america and then like a bunch of these
other little small banks
so i think that right there like i said
we know that subprime lenders are gonna
have repos because they just where
they're more riskier with their loans
but when you start seeing prime lenders
people that are getting like two three
four percent start defaulting on their
loans
for a bank like ally
how much do they have in loans in
relation to everything else now don't
they just
package their loans and resell them
every bank that's one funny thing that i
explained another person they didn't
believe me every bank keeps a chunk of
their portfolio to to make interest off
of but a lot of them bundle the paper
and they sell it to other banks because
they don't want the risk so if they
think the paper is risky they'll bundle
it and they'll sell it to another bank
and the funny thing is is every bank
gets allocated so much money every month
every quarter to lend and they gotta
lend it because if not they won't get
the next chunk of money or the next
chunk of money will be a little bit less
so the way i describe it is almost like
musical chairs you know well i'm gonna
bundle i'm gonna buy this paper from
graham and i'm gonna make three percent
or two percent and then i'm gonna hold
it for six months and then i'm gonna
sell to you jack for another maybe one
point two points whatever else and it
just keeps going around in circles
everybody that we didn't do enough loans
let's go buy some portfolio and they
just keep literally moving it around and
around and eventually when the music
stops and like i said the prices fall
now your portfolio assets are worth you
know about 75 of what the actual
portfolio is that's when they're going
to be screwed because nobody's going to
want to buy it they're going to buy it
for
50 cents on the dollar and
no with no interest back in and they're
going to be like oh i don't want to sell
it for that because i paid you know jack
x amount of dollars for it and
that's it and that's like i said that's
what's going to lead to all the banks
really tightening down and no longer
landing and that's what scares me is the
prices are going to be the prices but
when the lending stops then it doesn't
even matter what the prices is because
if the banks are not lending and they're
so afraid of this it starts with cars
and it usually will work its way up to
commercial loans real estate and because
a lot of the the big banks don't care
it's the small banks your your local
credit unions you're everything else
like that if you look like at america
first credit union here majority of
their their assets are in auto loans i
think their auto loan portfolio and
their housing portfolio are almost like
matched side by side you know but they
do that because they make more interest
make more money off of of cars
that's why a lot of people like to buy
car paper that's why a lot of these
hedge funds buy that but now it's like i
said now becomes yeah it's more money
but now it's a riskier asset because
when it's depreciating and two like
these people are driving them off crash
and not having insurance on them so
that's kind of what's going on with that
how are you trying to make money off
this
what are you doing differently um
what i'm doing right now is i've been
working a lot directly with banks to put
in offers to purchase cars directly
before they go to the auction so most
banks they don't like to sell to dealers
because dealers most of them are most
most dealers are [ __ ] so you know
and you could say a few naughty words
and we'll we'll leave them out for the
children who watch the iced coffee hour
yeah most of the dealers are not very
nice guys and so
um they don't like to deal with them
because they're always low balling and
stuff like that so the banks have to get
three competitive bids or ticket to
auction so i'm one of the few people
that are able to go to these these
dealers and buy some of these cars and
normally i buy cheap cars i don't like
to stay
extend myself any further because cheap
cars they're cash they move quickly i
take them to the auction i can sell 20
30 of them every week not have any
headaches but recently as you guys seen
we've been getting these exotic cars
left and right all these people that had
yeah ppp loans that put took 100k out of
their pvp loan put it down on a rolls
royce never made a payment you know
that's more the stuff that we're
starting to see now which is really
scary could you talk about that because
i see you going to la and you post these
pictures of these cars like a you know
kind of crash dash aston martin rolls
royces
audi's really nice cars and you're
buying them and bringing them back
a few you've explained were repos and
you've shown up and like the guys is
like yep here's the keys i get it can
you explain like how how you do this
like how you're involved in this and
like how does someone be
uh
get the
ability to go and do that um well first
you got to be a dealer or not a broker
that's the very first thing
the next thing is building a really
strong relationship with
a bank or lending institution because a
lot of the banks they're not dealers
they don't care about any of that they
just want to get rid of the asset to
them it's not a card it's just a it's a
pain in their butt the sooner they get
off their books they can go out and lend
more money so what i do is i'll go to
like a repo yard or a holding yard and
i'll try to get a hold of the banks
first before they go to the auction and
i'll try to say look i'll buy all those
cars at once right now i'll just write a
check and try to get everything i
possibly can they show me what they owe
you know how much money they're upside
down in it whatever else if i can pay a
little bit more on some cars and save a
little bit of money on the other cars
then i'll buy the deals and i think
that's why a lot of the banks like me
because no dealer ever wants to overpay
for a car they'll overpay at the auction
but if they buy a car from a friend or a
bank they always want to lowball them
and so that's one of the things that i
try to do is to purchase every single
thing from them directly now when we
actually go out to do repos like some of
these companies if i physically go out
there and help them repo the card
because some of these banks are back
east or it's like a small mom and pops
bank or credit union they don't have the
facilities or the personnel to do it so
we'll literally go door knocking for
them we'll knock on the door and we're
always nice hey you know we're here with
so and so bank they told us that you
know you're going to be surrendering
your car today you know can i get the
keys thank you so much is there anything
in the car you need to get most of the
people are pretty chill wait so they
know ahead of time that you're going to
be there you don't just show up because
i've seen videos on tick tock where the
guy pulls up in the truck is like all
right we found the car and they're
parked outside of a restaurant they tow
the car and the guy cause yo what are
you doing with my car yeah so like so
you asked them instead of like i okay no
um just for full transparency when when
it's my loan and i had my dealership
unfortunately i did it the other way i
would show up on my tow truck and i
would just snatch the car up i wouldn't
talk to him because every time i tried
to be nice and civil they would want to
start fights pull out guns uh i had one
guy stick his dog on me you know some
guy how did that okay what happened when
that when he sicked his dog on sick the
dog yeah oh i feel bad it's probably
made me look bad but when the dog jumped
i literally just threw him up over me
and he just flew over the truck
and so
wait
oh because as soon as i saw him i just
literally just freaked out and went like
this and he just just
floating oh yeah he was already in there
when was he fine
i didn't want to check i was more
worried about getting in the car and
getting out of here before i got bit in
the ass or she he said sick him yeah no
he literally grabbed the dog and went
like this and threw him and the dog
jumped it over and i just went over
there um i had another guy he he threw a
molotov cocktail in the car
i was like did this guy just like sit
there in his kitchen and actually cook
this up or was he just like sitting
outside with it but all of a sudden we
look back and i see a bottle break i'm
like oh this guy just threw a bottle at
the car and next thing you know my i
have it's called a spotter it's the guy
behind me that finds the car in the
regular car and then i come in a tow
truck he's like dude the car's on fire
the guy threw something i think it was a
molotov cocktail i was like are you
serious we pulled over car burnt to a
crisp
and then the guy the guy tried to sue us
because we uh it was full of his kids
gear his baby seats and uh
his music equipment everything else
personal property yeah and i'm like you
caught your own car on fire and then he
tried to call the insurance company to
get claimed to get paid and then we told
him that he did it so they paid us they
didn't give him any extra wow yeah i
mean unfortunately i got way too many
stories a lot i want to hear some more
stories yeah tell us another story oh
jeez um
god what can i tell you so what about
like personally endangering stories
where your life was threatened lucky
that's what jack is getting yeah
so one time we went to go pick up this
this and this one's gonna laugh because
this one's super embarrassing but it's
pretty hilarious so we had this guy that
um wanted we had this really cool almost
uh ford um explore minivan it was all
pimped out had tvs had all this stuff
it's a rare kind of van truck thing it's
hard to explain but it has a folding out
bed in the back it's made for camping
right so we're like okay this is gonna
be cool we're gonna snatch up this car
because i was trying to be nice to the
guy he wouldn't answer my phone calls so
i'm like i'm just going to pop the car
so i wind up popping this car and i'm
driving out of the way all of a sudden
the doors fly open this guy is butt
naked with like two other people in the
back of this van and one of the i said
this bigger guy rolls out and falls out
of the van butt naked rolling in the
middle of uh uh desert inn and uh
paradise and i'm like trying to take off
with the car and all of a sudden the
cops pull us over we wind up getting
arrested that night because they said we
did it like lawfully but that one i
guess wasn't really that threatening but
it was just absolutely hilarious i've
never seen somebody naked like fall out
of the back of a van but i've had like
you know want to be gangbangers pull out
guns i had a pimp one time pull out a
gun on us and told us we can't take his
car what do you do in a situation like
that i usually pull my gun out no are
you serious yeah i'm not going to get
shot yeah but don't you just say take
the car yeah you're getting shot if you
no because most of these guys have never
pulled the trigger so they're
willing to risk that like take the
chance because you don't know these
people it's kind of hard it's like
reflex i mean think about it it's like
if i throw something in your face you're
going to want to go like this so as soon
as i see it that's the first thing i do
so nasa's word like like if you pull out
a gun or if not you but the other person
do you like aiming yeah
so if someone pulls out a boom stick
and they point the boomstick at you do
you just like point it back at them or
do they just show you a gun and then you
show them a gun sometimes if they they
do the little flexing the showing then
i'll i'll show mine boomstick or i'll
actually like if they point it at me
then i'll point back but that's those
are that's only happened twice but why
is it why would that be worth
taking the chance wouldn't you say that
they point a boom stick at you
all right you know what let me you know
leave call the police handle it another
way i i'll be honest with you that's
stupid i don't recommend anybody doing
that it's just it was more of a reaction
thing it's just like so what happened in
these in these two instances where you
guys had each of your boots oh you're
gonna on on the one guy the the pimp he
actually came paid the car off in full
apologized and brought me rolling uh
smoke barbecue
said he just broke up with his
girlfriend he lost his main
girlfriend and he was really heartbroken
and upset and frustrated that was
probably the nicest one the other guy um
he called the cops on me but when the
cop showed i guess he had like two
warrants out for his arrest and so they
they went up taking him away i thought i
was going to go to jail because i admit
i was like yeah i did point a gun at him
but he pointed one at me first or
boomstick at me is it true people do
this thing
oh yeah like i had the thing like we we
used to have these crazy like um
off-site sales and we used to do like
these crazy giveaways so i used to give
away a car like once a month like to do
something funny and we actually have
people that will show up because they
see all the people they think there's a
lot of money they'll try to show up and
like you know point the finger thing
like hey man i got money i know you got
all these people's tax returns in the
bank give it to me you know it's funny
at one time they did it with my dad my
dad just told him to get out of there
and he threw a chair at him and the guy
who ended up running away which i don't
recommend doing that but
it's it's one of the things of the
business i don't like that's why the
repo part the repo the being you know
like the people are super aggressive
like i love the the giving cars away
with the funny contest we used to do
like we whoever's saying the worst song
we give you a car um if you throw a
football through hoop we give you a car
you know uh just funny stuff but then
you get the bad things where you have
people like that's the thing everyone
thinks dealers are bad and they're
horrible people for every one bad dealer
there's 10 000 bad customers
um i'll tell you some of the bad stuff
like we've had people like lie to us
about
their bank check stubs the they'll give
us fake ones they'll give us a fake
social security number it's called the
cpn they'll give us this number we'll
run it oh everything's good this
person's got good credit all of a sudden
two weeks later the bank calls me hey
lucky this loan is not legit these
people have fake documents
i'm like oh crap so the bank wants their
money back now i gotta go find the car
most time when these people commit fraud
they just disappear with the cars why is
that fall on you so every dealer has to
sign an agreement with a bank so and
this is the part that people don't know
about and this is why people like why
was the dealer so mad why won't he lower
the price it's because as a dealer we're
on the hook for depending on your
recourse it could be a one payment it's
a three payment recourse so if you as
the consumer doesn't make the first
three payments
and you just take off i have to give the
bank 100 of the money back and i have to
chase you for it but as long as they
make the first few payments then then
we're in the clear but a lot of these
people they they don't that's what we're
seeing now a lot of people are first
second third payment defaults or the the
one thing is if they give you fraudulent
documents and they can prove it then
they can come back a year from now and
say hey uh this document was fake this
is not a real driver's license we need
our thirty thousand dollars back and
you're like well i don't know where the
guy is it's been a year the car's gone
maybe it's in mexico or canada or
something and we have no recourse have
you ever just completely lost cars
hundreds
what happens you have insurance for that
it's cost of doing business when people
ask me like because that was one of the
reasons i left the business is because
everybody thought we were rich when you
have like 200 cars on your lot and
you're selling cars and you see all this
stuff they're like man lucky you're
doing really well you got all this money
i was broke i'm not even gonna lie most
dealers will lie
i had two million dollars in
and flooring lines which is lines of
credit we were constantly paying
payments so every time you drive by a
dealership think of like each car on
their lots costing them 500 to a
thousand dollars a month and then every
month we lose maybe one maybe two cars
whether somebody steals them somebody
does bank fraud and and pulls us over
you know um i've man like i said they
they do whatever it takes they'll run
off with your cars i've had people i'd
chase down on test drives like nice old
people oh we just want to drive it
around okay no problem folks here go
ahead drive it around feel safe let me
know what you think and we this older
couple i think they're in their 80s they
drove out my car to mexico
yeah they left they left it on at a bus
stop and said sorry i left a note
did they just need a ride
probably they were broke and needed a
ride and like that yeah you send to go
pick it up in mexico um we have repo
companies all over the us so we just
tell them to pick it up and take it to a
local auction because by the time i fly
down there or ship it back it just
wasn't worth the headache or the problem
but that's some of the stuff that we
have to deal with you know and and the
worst thing is is like we dealers will
be more aggressive they'll tell us that
we need more money down we have to do
this and people like dealers are so mean
and rude like a lot of people don't
realize if you have let's say you're a
first-time buyer and i'm selling you
that 2020 twitter camera we were talking
about if you have good credit or okay
credit the bank is probably gonna charge
me like maybe a thousand eight hundred
bucks to buy your deal but if you have
bad credit they could charge me up to
two thousand dollars three thousand
dollars and then on top of that they'll
add two to three month recourse so now i
was hoping to make maybe three thousand
dollars on the car but if your buy fees
twenty five hundred dollars for the bank
to take your loan i'm making five
hundred
i got to pay my sales guy commission to
500 bucks my finance person of you know
250 and i have you know office personnel
that needs 10 plus overhead that's why i
hated the business it's like the banks
made all the money one thing i've never
understood about car dealerships is you
talk with the sales rep and then you
give them a price you're comfortable
paying the car let's say it's it's
listed at thirty thousand dollars and
you say i can do twenty eight thousand
dollars and then they go and they talk
to their manager
right like what is that interaction like
and also how do you actually come upon a
price they were able to agree on for the
car is there a price floor that is the
base that you can hit as a consumer how
can you find that price floor oh that's
the problem a lot of dealerships uh just
play a lot of stupid games i never did
that like when you know like advertising
like you looking for a car and you see
oh look this car is thirty thousand
dollars that's the car i want so you go
drive there it's thirty thousand like
origination plus stock fee plus
destination yeah service conditioning
reconditioning
whatever fee you know so now it's 38 000
and you're just like that's not what i
wanted i wanted this for 30. so that's
the first one so i never did that if my
car was 35 grand it's 35 000. i put it
on there i didn't care if car gurus told
me i was overpriced craigslist facebook
marketplace i'd rather have you show up
knowing the price that's that was the
first step but a lot of dealers i'll
tell them hey look with your credit
and what i bought the car for i need to
make x amount of dollars this is what
i'm gonna charge you i need to get
thirty two thousand five you
i would show them and what would they
what was their reaction do you think it
was actually it worked in your favor
yeah well because it wasn't [ __ ] i
was like you know hey this is what it is
folks if you have good credit i could i
can go down to 31. but you have bad
credit bank's going to charge me 1500
and sometimes i'd even show him look
this is this is what it is this is what
you're charging me and it sometimes
they'd freak out and they had no idea
most people don't know how it works
that's why i try to talk about it on my
channel but like most these dealers
how can i get gross how can i get the
most money so instead of making your i'd
rather get you pleasant in and out in an
hour and you tell all your friends about
me i've only made a thousand dollars off
you but hopefully you'll tell you know
graham then you'll tell alex you know
and go so on and so on these guys they
don't care the old dealerships of the
guys that like used to send you
christmas cards and stuff like that
those days are gone these guys just want
to rip your head off bury you in a car
and then kick you down the road and just
it's it's not their problem me i'd
rather make sure you're happy don't put
you too far into debt so this way every
year you can come back and buy another
car for me that's what i want and a lot
of dealers got away from that they got
really focused on the gross i was more
on the volume model like walmart so what
about when the sales rep goes and speaks
with a manager what are they trying to
establish does the sales rep already
know the price floor for the base they
can tell the 400 or something yeah well
sometimes some dealers will tell the
sales people but some don't because they
don't want the sales people to give away
the car yeah and so i have a feeling if
they really knew they would
automatically just come back down to
that product because they don't care
they want the sale yeah any type of
attention they're like the customer's
like oh yeah this car is 32 000 32 000
okay 2850. you know it's like yeah
so so on a let's say a 30 000 car or a
camry let's say it's it's it's you know
35 or whatever what is the price what
would the price floor be about for a car
of that price um usually you take about
10 15 off of that so
let's say if you put it out for 32
they're probably into it like maybe 28
28 you know but that's why like people
don't understand car business is still a
business they got to make money i hated
it when people were like well you're
making 500 bucks
i'm like are you kidding me i go would
you wake up in the morning and take on
all this debt and talk to people like
you for 500
and i used to love telling them that
they would get so mad people like me i
was like yeah you're sitting there
yelling at me being mean to me because i
always used to go out like my my
commercials that's why i started doing
youtube but another reason is because i
had these funny commercials so i was i
always wanted to make people laugh and
joke so when they came into my
dealership they were smiling instead of
like angry and mad and don't talk to me
i don't want you to sell me anything
i'll get you when i need you okay no
problem folks i'll be standing right
over here let me know whatever you need
i get yelled at more hey good morning
folks how you guys doing
you know go get ben get out of here kick
rocks you know i'm just like dude you're
in my business like i could be cause i
think you're trying to sell them
something yeah so if you're nice it's
like oh he's buttering me up he's gonna
try to extract money from me now oh yeah
i used to love it like i don't think
like when people try to play hardball i
don't want to argue i'm like look folks
i can do 28.50 that's all i can do
i want 27 sir i can do 20 50. that's it
oh and they start arguing i'm like look
just take this or get out of my shop
i don't care i don't care if i sell to
you i sell to somebody else somebody's
going to buy it so it's either you or
them and i'll get to the point where i
just started kicking people out of my
lot i know i probably lost a lot of
sales out of it but it just wasn't worth
the headache and i'd rather not burn a
relationship with a customer where i'm
like look folks i'm being 100 honest
this is all we can afford and this is
what we're going to do and so i do admit
it was a pain in the butt but i have
been recently talking about maybe
opening up another dealership here in
vegas so i'm kind of when you initially
had that dealership what kind of
dealership was it you know when i sold
my dealership it was the happiest day of
my life but it was also like the saddest
because i actually do enjoy like you
know hanging out with with people
selling cars yeah because i tell people
it's like you know like you were real
estate you know when you sold somebody a
house you know you see them light up
they're super excited you know you're
making commission but it's like you're a
part of somebody's like life future
whatever else and the way i did it is
just i i actually had a lot of fun the
last few years i i stopped caring about
it as a business and i made it more of
like just like i hate to say a social
experiment just having fun and doing
whatever
um but the reason why i'm thinking about
doing it now is i started back in 2012
when everything was going bad and
everything was going down and people
told me i was a fool just like when they
were trying to buy real estate same
thing with this so i decided you know
why not get back into it because
this time around i want to do more of
the financing myself i want to hold my
own paper i want to become like my own
is that dangerous it is a little
dangerous you know you you are financing
people with your own money but the
profits are just crazy now can you pull
money together from investors like let's
just say hey you know like i could give
you some financing give you 500 grand go
and loan this out as you see fit
can you can you accept money from other
people to then yeah
yeah so part of the
the group that i'm talking to they
actually own a hedge fund and they were
talking about giving me money to go out
and do loans because we were kind of
talking about like you know like the
whole influencer uh uh auto sales like
financing people like ourselves where
you know if you go into a bank and
you're like hey i'm a youtuber here's my
bank statements i make you know 10 20 30
40 000 a month off of youtube most banks
don't have a category to stick you in
they put you as like self-employed
something bad and then a lot of people
get turned down especially for like 60
to like 120 000
car financing so i figured i may do a
few cars like that to build like the
influencer brand and do specialty
financing but also to help a lot of
people because i remember in 2012 when i
started i was doing a lot of cheap cars
all my cars were under 999 bucks under
10 grand
and i helped so many people people that
i saw during the 08 you know 0.506 or
708 that were only construction
companies that own three to five to six
to ten houses you know they lost
everything and now they're buying a
ten thousand dollar car for me to get
back on their feet so not saying it i'm
hoping it doesn't happen this go around
but i think that the market's gonna be
wide open and a lot of these dealers are
so over leveraged that i think now the
time is right to actually get back in
just for
fun sake i got two more questions for
you okay so number one is before this
you said you're gonna tell us how you
actually make money and how we're gonna
be very surprised by that so we get into
that then also we have three patreon
questions that we're gonna get to right
after that so how do you make money
lucky how do i make money um first is
only fans i'm joking uh first is
basically um training dealers setting up
dealerships um
setting up different types of franchises
almost like houston what is chicken i do
the same thing for dealerships i try to
set them up
do the correct things get them lines of
credit financing set up the rental car
companies lines of credit help them get
fleet lines so they can multiply their
vehicles but the big thing that i do is
i actually go out and i buy portfolio
from different banks so one of my jobs
or one of the things i like to do for
fun is i'll go talk to banks and see how
their numbers are performing so a lot of
my numbers that i get is a lot of inside
information so when people are like well
where can i look this up or how can i
look at it you can't unless you work for
the bank which they'll never tell you
that's how i see the default rates i see
what the average loan is what the
average payment is which is a thousand
bucks which is awful and so we go around
and my job is to go basically knock on
doors ask the bank hey do you have any
paper you want to sell three to five to
ten million dollars we only do those
chunks and then what do you do with
those huge chunks so once they tell me
what they they have i look at it i put a
value on to it and then my job is to go
find another bank that's willing to
purchase it so you wholesale
wholesale paper yeah it's almost like
how you guys wholesale houses you get
the note and then we just shop it around
exact same thing but just with banks
your dealership training kind of sounds
like if you listen to our homozy podcast
what do you do with the gym launch 100
it's like it's the same concepts once
you learn the system and you can expand
it like that's why i started doing
youtube because it's like i loved
marketing all my funny ads on facebook
just blew up so i figured let me try
youtube you know and uh but i really
like the fact of like i don't want to
get out of the automotive industry
because i loved it so much but i keep
trying to get away with it i'm trying to
do youtube more and more but the more i
do youtube i feel like more people like
dude show us how to do this show us how
to do that come on
oh no i have a course but it's i want to
show people i don't want to charge
people i want to show them like like
when we walk into the repo yards we walk
into the auction or like next time when
we go to la um i'll take you in one of
the repo yards i think you'll laugh
you'll see
ferraris lamborghinis trucks motorhomes
taco trucks like everything you know
watches like when i go to the feds oh
that's one you gotta come with me when
we go to the fed auctions when they
impound all the stuff from the drug
dealers we bid on couches tvs um i
remember we bought this like uh like
three thousand pound elephant like
marble statue we couldn't move it we
ended up selling it to another guy
because we were trying to get it back
here to vegas but you could buy the most
crazy stuff at some of these auctions
okay and that's something i'll hopefully
in the future i'll be able to take you
guys to and then what about uh any any
other income sources you could think of
um i mean obviously the flipping cars
you guys see that on my youtube channel
and instagram we go out we buy cars from
the auction stuff like that um the next
one is where we're getting ready to set
up a
bank where we can actually start funding
multiple dealers and we're purchasing
vehicles from them so almost like the
company's called my vehicle value
it's still up and running we're still
going through the software phase but
we're buying about a thousand cars a
month through california nevada new
mexico arizona and colorado walk us
through because i know you've had a
bunch of different jobs and you've
worked in the car industry but doing a
lot of different things within the car
industry walk us through your income
over time how it's gone up how it's gone
down how it you know the o8 recession
affected it and what you were doing at
each time oh geez when i first started
this was back in like 2000 i had a shop
in chinatown and i was just just a
regular mechanic i was 18 years old i
wanted to work on cars at that time i
actually wanted to do music but i ended
up getting in the cars so i was like i'm
gonna make some money and then pay for
school and whatever else and so i
started working on just different types
of cars in the area i started doing the
body kits this is when fast and furious
was really popular we worked on the most
junkiest cars ever and i think i was
clearing maybe
thirty thousand dollars a year after
paying all my expenses back in 2000 you
know yeah but i thought i was falling i
was an 18 year old kid just in for
inflation that's like 700 grand yeah i
know exactly yeah and so but i mean i
was i was 18 years old i had this like
crazy mazda rx-7 and so i was sick yeah
so i started fixing up more and more
cars fast forward two years later and i
started to get into customizing i was
like i wanna i wanna work on some nicer
cars i wanna do like this is when pimp
my ride and overhauling was like at its
peak everybody and their grandma was
like bro i got 20 grand let's do
something crazy to my car so we just
started doing all this crazy stuff
that was my first year i broke a hundred
thousand dollars i think i was like in
my like early twenties and i was just
super really good yeah and i was like
man this is great i can't wait so we
opened up a body shop after that fast
forward a few years and we were doing
really really well and that was the
first year that's when i was at my worst
my douchiest i was a 25 year old kid
living in turnberry towers back in the
day i think my rent my penthouse was
like six grand a month i was driving a
05 or 06 bentley continental gt
convertible wow i mean you couldn't tell
me nothing i thought i was the man i
arrived i was such an idiot did you
still work on cars or you just oh no i
worked on cars i i realized this is when
i started developing my skills for
marketing because
i would hire people and they were way
faster than me i could do stuff better
but they could do it much much faster
than me that's when i decided to step
back and more of a sales role management
because my guys couldn't sell a job to
save their lives or i'd go in there hey
man we're going to spend 20 grand this
is what we're going to do is we're going
to do sign here and it just kind of just
kind of flowed so then i just started
door knocking asking people for their
business and that's actually what led me
to doing like exotic cars when i was
door knocking i ran across dream car
exotics they were the biggest rental car
company here in vegas there was no
ferrari lamborghini dealership here so
there was nowhere for them to send their
cars they either had to send them to
scottsdale or ship them to la so i was
like well let me work on your cars i
figured working on a ferrari can't be
that hard it must be simple it's all the
same stuff and we worked on a few 355s
and 360s
they're easier to work on than a honda
core wow i thought it'd be super
complicated we need all these crazy
tools no so we were doing timing belts
swapping out clutches because these guys
were doing clutch drops in these rentals
and blowing them up um i flew to new
york did this like training class for a
lot of these italian cars came back and
i was like i'm going to do exotic cars
i'm going to specialize in this and so
we reopened rebranded i think the
company it was
las vegas motor works we did nothing but
exotic cars and highland cars anything
under 60k i would consider them a
peasant and throw them out of my shop
that was the year i went down in income
i went i think i was making like a
hundred grand
what were you making before that when
you're done 250 that was when you were
doing the bentley continental yeah i was
i was working on regular cars this is
where
the switch came on so during that time i
saw these people that couldn't afford
these cars you know they'd buy a brand
new 80 000 truck and then fix it up drop
20 grand and turn on sell it and go buy
another one or then to go buy a maserati
uh a ferrari a lambo you know and they
just kept buying all these crazy cars
and i was charging these people 10 20 30
000 and they're all using their credit
cards nobody's paying cash anymore which
i started notice that because my my
credit card bill was insane but after
paying my people after paying my
extravagant living expenses i i made 150
000 less that year
and it blew my mind so i was like you
know what i'm gonna start
branching out so i opened up two or
three locations of auto repair doing
regular cars and i got up to about back
to the 250 marker working on regular
cars but i got too caught up in the
mystique of working on the exotic cars i
thought that was the way because
everybody wanted to come hang out at my
shop i had a couch area like this where
my friends would come out and this was a
glass wall and we'd watch the guys work
on the cars and do stuff like that and i
thought it was really cool and that's
when i got on this tv show if you google
it's tlc's rides i was on the uh
the pilot for that they came here and
shot in vegas so that was way back in
oh six oh seven i think that was the
prime time of that yeah i was hitting my
ride and i was such an interview
after cribs yeah they filmed the pilot
and they're like true life can we come
back and film some more and i'm like are
you guys gonna pay me they're like no
i'm like why am i gonna film like i
thought it was if i want to know now
like i did back then i could have been
oc choppers or something special but i
just got irritated because i'd i'd put
an alternator into a car and like okay
that looks good now go ahead take it
back out and walk back and do it again
i'm like what are you talking about i
just put the alternator in this car why
am i going to take it back out and go
back again oh we want to capture from a
different angle this time and that's
when i first started learning about how
these media companies did that but
anyways i i told them though i really
lost an opportunity and then
08 happened market collapsed everything
went bad i actually decided to join the
army when i was 20 something i figured i
was going to take a break from the car
business joined the army and went and
flipped houses in texas for about two
years
and then that was fun i actually i made
more money down there and i was stupid i
missed vegas and i came back
and then i came back to vegas and then i
opened up my dealership in my rental car
company how much were you making
flipping houses not to sound bad it was
so easy down there because nobody had
any style everybody was like super
country oaky i know this is probably
going to be roasted in the comment
section but like everything was barnyard
and wooden doors and i hated it so we
were doing everything modern and so we'd
buy these like little tiny houses for
like 20 30 grand i mean this is so cheap
back then this is like in arlington and
fort worth and dallas
and we would just buy these houses
modernize them we'd put you know smart
dials smart uh keypads in them we would
do modern fixtures we would do like
concrete countertops way back then we
were doing hardwoods instead of carpet
everybody was doing carpet and like
veneer walls it was awful i their style
down there was just completely weird so
we just copied everything we did here in
vegas and it just worked out really
really well we met a hard money lender
out there and we didn't ever look for
houses he just gave us all the houses
that people defaulted on which was
really bad that's when i first really
learned about repo
this guy had so many houses he had a
fund of just
just giving people money to get houses
oh yeah these guys gave us 20 grand down
they tore down everything down the studs
and they found termites and they walked
away from the property do you guys want
it i'll give you six months no payments
and no interest sure we'd take it on he
wouldn't we'd balance out his books we'd
fix the house up turn on sell it we make
our profit he'd make his big back his
investors were happy it was really
really good he was actually mad when we
left when i came back here to vegas i
reached out to him to see if he could
get back into flipping houses and his
investors didn't want to do the vegas
market because at that time we were one
of the biggest ones that crashed so then
i just got back into cars and opened up
my dealership and started that way
because like i said when i came back
here
people that i saw that were driving
lambos and ferraris were driving like
2003 toyota corollas and camrys because
they couldn't afford anything that's the
first time i learned the term
cross-collateralization when they lost
one thing they lost it all and it was
crazy i mean people fell hard so i
opened up the dealership started selling
cars at that time i think we were
clearing maybe 80 000 a year at that
time wasn't a whole lot and then it's
same thing i went bigger i got the two
lots peaked at like 250 300 cars
still would make like 100k here
couldn't couldn't crack the mold until i
started doing uh these like when i just
stopped carrying really i started doing
the funny ads started selling uh i hate
to sit started selling cheaper cars
again and just got back to the basics
and that's why on my channel i can do
exotic cars i can do all these fancy
stuff but if you just sell cheap
affordable transportation your money you
make your money by far you usually make
double or triple where when i sell like
a like this bentley bentego or this
rolls royce i'm going to sell it i'll
make like 50 grand but i tied up 120 000
and it's gonna sit there for you know a
month and a half while i'm fixing it and
waiting for parts i could have bought 70
80 regular cars and maybe double my
money off of that by then so that's kind
of why i decided to do that but that was
kind of my flow of the business now with
youtube and everything else um i'm
hoping this year to crack the 450 500k
marker that's my goal i really want to
get get to that point but my biggest
goal is and you're going to laugh and i
guess this name's radio thing i want no
debt the only debt i want is my car
payment that's why i don't mind spending
a crazy amount on a car because i don't
know credit cards i don't own a house
you know which people think it's crazy
but i i can't afford to i can't i can't
afford it i just don't want to afford to
overpay for a house i just think it's
stupid i'd rather just wait and use my
money to make money's better off
invested in cars at this point yeah you
know and it's just like no matter what
happens like we talked about investing
stocks i just feel safer with the car
market and now that you know the the the
bear market is here and the gravy
train's gone and everybody's a magical
investing wizard all the money is coming
back to the automotive industry for for
high interest lending so i think that'll
open up a lot a lot of opportunities
that's why i'm interested in starting a
dealership now because these guys are
going to make more money on their
investment and they can't get in the
stock market now so now they're going
back to
hard money landing with cars and houses
you want to ask the patreon questions
yeah so for those that don't know we
have a patreon down below in the
description but uh part of the perks of
that could be asking our guests
questions along with a whole bunch of
other uh benefits like getting the
episode early without ads by the way but
uh what do we got here well first of all
i just want to mention i just got a text
from an alex hormozy and he sent me over
his wife laila hormozy's phone number
and it looks like we're gonna have laila
hormozy on the podcast potentially next
sunday so if you're still watching at
this point be very excited for the next
sunday because that's gonna be a crazy
yeah yeah you know what actually if you
want to get in and ask her questions uh
we'll link to the patreon down below in
the description i'm not sure when we're
going to be doing this but
potentially you could ask her questions
that we'll ask that brings me to a great
point graham if you haven't followed me
on instagram
what is one thing that you would do
differently if you could go back in time
and who is your mentor um my one of my
mentors the car business unfortunately
people are not that friendly and they
don't want to share knowledge and so one
of the nicest guys ever met his name is
uh is tony fernandez he owns a
dealership here in vegas
he was one of the few dealers that would
give me words of encouragement tell me a
little bit about how to stay away from
some of the problems and just an overall
great guy so i i wouldn't call i mean i
guess he could be a mentor because he
did teach me quite a lot about the
business and about life so i would say
that probably be him and if i could do
one thing differently um
it would be i would have done buy here
pay here which is doing your own auto
loan portfolio way back in the day
because if i would have done that back
when i first started
i'd be
just a millionaire when you're a bank
that's where you make all your money so
that's probably my biggest mistake is i
didn't do it holding the notes and
collecting yeah i was too busy trying to
learn other banks programs because i
didn't want the headache i didn't want
the overhead but then i wound up working
in the wrong way because at the end of
the day if i would have done that i
would have been doing just like the
banks just sitting back collecting money
and selling paper now colin l asks what
are your thoughts on sponsorship revenue
and what is your plan for your channel
if sponsorship revenue declines i mean i
think it's a great source i'm probably
one of the few channels that i still to
this day i haven't taken really hardly
any sponsors i'm kind of just going off
of my own dollar like a lot of people
don't realize that i spend my own money
running my channel um i think i make
maybe five six grand a month in ad
revenue which is not a whole lot
but i would say that you know i should
have taken it on probably a little bit
earlier i was actually following
graham's thing because i noticed when
you first started you didn't take a lot
of sponsors and i didn't want to sell
out if i want to have a sponsor i want
it to be something legit where i can
either feel it helps my my audience out
or it's something i believe in yeah and
unfortunately my industry in the
automotive business there's not a whole
lot i believe in or trust all right so
this is kind of a
controversial question from matan he
says you've been in the car industry for
a long time you know how all the
different companies make money is it not
obvious to you that tesla is winning on
all fronts and is clearly going to take
over the industry if they haven't done
so already
ooh
that's a good question
making their own materials for their
cars which not a lot of other car
companies are doing correct so
like i said tesla is great because they
were first to market
but if you look at a porsche tycon
compared to a tesla it's like looking
like at a kia and a ferrari it's the
build quality is completely different i
know these people in tesla are going to
be like oh my god no it's the best car
take the time look at like the
technology is there their autopilot is
much further ahead chevy and hyundai are
going to be the first to catch up with
it but when it comes to build quality
they make better uh products like uh
ford honda chevy toyota because just the
build quality is much better parts um
being able to fix your car they have
that leaps and bounds ahead of them
tesla is highly profitable because
they're building something that's very
niche they got the apple effect you know
this phone costs a few bucks to make but
it's got the brand behind it and it's
got the fans the loyal fans behind it so
yeah they are first to market and
they're first to sell direct to
consumers but right now they're
constrained they can't grow any faster
unless they physically start buying
franchise stores so and plus too like a
lot of the other manufacturers their
battery life is better than tesla's you
know so when all these cheaper cars cost
half the price and ikea can go twice the
distance as your tesla and on top of
that it costs half as much to fix and
they have more battery battery
technology where they can repair cells
instead of replacing a whole 20 000
battery which the new ones don't have
that tesla fixed that but you know i
that's what i believe is everybody's
going to catch up to tesla tesla was
just first to market give it about five
years and the market share is going to
change because already right now believe
it or not volkswagen has more ev
vehicles than anybody else coming out
next year i think they have 14 or 15
models so you know like i said
everyone's playing catch-up and so now
that they know that the market's there
and they're building that infrastructure
which uh was a charge america which is
volkswagen they're building all these
systems everybody's just waiting and
they're gonna unveil their stuff and
it's gonna be very very surprising all
right are there any other random things
of knowledge or a crazy story or
something you would hope we had asked
something you wanted to share oh geez um
i guess i can tell you really quick
before we get off um some of my amazing
down payments so in the car business we
take pretty much everything we're always
talking about cars whatever else and i
used to run these ads we'll take
anything down you know and we had one
lady she brought in like a uh this puppy
i think it was called a frenchie and i
didn't realize there were like three
thousand dollar dogs and so she brought
it in we gave her like 500 bucks as a
trade return and sold the dog for two
grand which was hilarious so we started
doing these like traded anything special
we had people bringing in motorized
scooters uh fake legs we had one guy
fake legs a fake leg and they brought it
in
as collateral for yeah he's like he's
like what will you get me down i was
like i'll give you a dollar for it just
he left it there you're taking
everything
we've got what did you do with the fake
leg
we actually left it we sold it for 500
no that was that bucks the award for the
salesman that sold the most cars that
month so i told you we have a special we
have a very special award and i stuck
like like 300 inside the leg and then i
gave it to him and said this is your
championship cup don't lose it so but
that was one of the things we did but
we've had i've had people show up at
gold bars i've had people show up with
guns
um
i've had these like strippers one time
like they showed up because my first
dealership was right next door to
treasures and so we used to get the
dancers coming by all the time and they
would ask me well hey i need i want to
get a car i need to get a car oh yeah
three four thousand dollars down that's
all you need you can roll with this car
oh was there anything we could work out
i'm like yeah just work out payments
give him you know give me the money and
i'll i'll get you the car well is there
anything you could do that maybe you
like or something that turns you on and
i'm like yeah you know what turns me on
what money pay me and so we used to i
loved it every week they would try to
come in like sweet talk and i'm like no
and then that same girl i won't mention
her name because i'm still friends with
her on facebook
she came in one day and we had this i
think it was like a 2014 lexus is uh 300
and it was pearl white with like this
pink christian viewer interior total
stripper car and so she came in and i
was like you need six grand down to get
this car she's like well i got 1500
bucks is it great all you need is a few
bucks more and you can drive it away
hour later she shows up with this older
gentleman
gives me 1500 bucks oh yeah i'm here for
almost her name i'm here for so and so
we'll call her misty i'm here for misty
let's uh um this is her down payment oh
okay cool yeah i i was like are you her
dad or unknown or boyfriend hour later
another guy comes in
same thing oh hey i'm misty's boyfriend
she told me that um leave like 500 bucks
a thousand he's like i got like 1800
bucks sure and literally within a day
she had like several men show up and
just give me money and then
she drove away the car so that's some of
the the crazy stuff that like we would
deal with all the time strippers
pimps um i mean like like i said i've
had people trade in a helicopter i got a
bell helicopter out of somebody's
backyard they didn't know what it was
their friend left it there they were
supposed to use it for an event yeah and
so we took it in on trade we actually
sold it for i think it was like 180k
you sold a helicopter
they gave you that as a down payment for
what car um it was a 20
2010 escalade how many know what to sell
that for
no but think about it it's like how do
you sell a helicopter what is it worth
it i don't know no that's what we did we
looked on craigslist and we're like does
it run he's like i don't know and i was
like well how did you guys get it there
he's like oh we brought it in here on a
truck and i'm like so you just brought
it in the truck and stuck it in your
backyard he's like yeah so we were
actually because my my dealership was by
the freeway so we were going to like
stick it on the side of my sign and buy
the freeway we're like we'll just use it
as a big sign as a joke and i think we
gave him like five thousand dollars in
trade and then once we found out how
much this thing was worth they it was
180k but i think we had to spend about
30 thousand dollars because i guess the
blades are time related they have to be
a certain year's amount of old and they
have to be installed so the guy ended up
bringing it together is at the north las
vegas airport but we got it fixed up we
paid him the money and he found a guy
that bought it and uh i thought there
would be like a title or some sort of
paperwork no just give him a helicopter
yeah and i was like i was like okay but
i mean like yeah we've we've gotten all
kinds of crazy stuff so i've had
that stolen cars um i don't know if you
saw some of my instagram stories like
people offering us drugs all the time i
got you know i got coke i got hookers i
got weed plumbers offering hail fix your
pipes never if i can use something like
that like hey man i'll work up like i
had one guy that didn't have any money
but he was in construction but he needed
to make need to do something i had to
remodel our office just for a down
payment because it's like at least he's
got a skill yeah that he can help me
with i was like can i need a landscaper
same thing i had to redo my parents
house so stuff like that i actually
looked for but i never got like that
that often it was always something crazy
like bro i got a fur coat i'm like what
am i gonna do with a fur coat it's las
vegas
it's a twelve thousand dollar four coat
well good sell it for six and give me
the money you know oh just take it for
trade and so it's just like i literally
became a pawn shop we had tvs like my
whole shop was full of it looked like
you're would you sell this stuff out of
the pond like people would get buying
for my sales and they'd see like all
year yeah my sales guys were being lazy
and they were sitting there not doing
anything i would say hey post this stuff
up for sale so they'd post cars for sale
on facebook and then they'd post all of
our crap that we took in on trades and
then i would split the money with them
so whatever we sold it for so if we had
like this microphone and we sold it for
50 bucks they would keep 25 i get 25 and
we just kept doing that on all the items
we get and it was crazy i couldn't
believe it this guy these people show up
10 20 30 tvs one time
um i guess he bought him from some
auction and showed up with all and they
all worked and we sold each one for 100
bucks wow so it's it's crazy but yeah
that's that's pretty much some of the
the pg stuff the other stuff i'll tell
you offline but that's some of the weird
stuff that we've gotten as far as trades
and everything else that's crazy well
thank you so much for coming on man
thank you for sharing these stories it
was amazing yeah thank you guys so much
for having me and it's been uh yeah it's
one one year of uh friendship and one uh
iced coffee hour it's really great well
happy to celebrate that i'll link to
your information down below in the
description as well as a purple flare
wraps if you guys are looking for a good
rap company they wrap the lotus uh
you'll see some pictures of it very
shortly actually you know what i'll
throw up a picture of it right here they
did such a good job as with you lucky
trying to get that car up and running so
thank you guys so much also oh lucky did
you get your free stock down below in
the description be on instagram
public.com
you got the free stock uh
wow i never closed that out that was
funny